quand on a des des toiles dans des plus
grands musées du monde entier là on est
sûr de postérité
c'est pas ce qui me pousse en avant
le questionnaire vous allez répondre
tous les deux votre mot préféré espoir
lumière
pas conventionnel c'est conformiste
conformiste
le bruit que vous aimez
à le son du bronze d'un gomme d'un gong
tibétain que j'ai et qui fait exister le
silence le son le bruit que vous aimez
vous faire une réponse très littéraire
nous sommes l'année Verlaine j'aime
beaucoup Verlaine Verlaine était tout
fait entre autres par Clovis et je me
rappelle toujours entre autres ce verre
de Verlaine l'inflexion des voix chers
qui se sont tues et le son le bruit que
vous détestez
de façon générale
tout bruit je trouve que le bruit de la
pollution probablement la plus terrible
mais disons que c'est le bruit d'une
arme à feu d'accord
les bruits qui ne sont pas
biodégradables
votre juron gros mots blasphème favori
là c'est biodégradable merde
mais il m'arrive parfois dans les
moments de très grande irritation d'être
nettement plus grossier et de dire quoi
bordel à cul
pas mal aux femmes pour illustrer
nouveau billet de banque
je peux vous dire cette question de
ma part
vous savez aujourd'hui mettre
Saint-Louis sur un billet de banque
c'est quand même un peu un défi à la
laïcité bon homme moi c'est Guillaume 9
duc d'Aquitaine duc d'Aquitaine poète
oui un des premiers troubadours qui a eu
au 12e siècle l'audace d'écrire je vais
faire un poème sur le pur néant sur le
pur droit sur le droit néon sur le pur
rien sur le pur rien et par ailleurs il
était le grand-père d'Aliénor qui était
à la fois reine de France et reine
d'Angleterre c'était déjà le début de
l'Europe le métier que vous n'auriez pas
aimé faire juge oh la même chose je suis
très bien la plante l'arbre ou l'animal
dans lequel vous aimeriez être réincarné
Jacques Le Goff
simplement un chat et vous moi je
préfère un arbre le Jingo biloba et ça a
l'air un peu savant c'est un arbre qui a
traversé
c'est un arbre qui restait toujours
semblable à lui-même à travers les airs
géologiques alors si Dieu existe Jacques
Legoff qui aimeriez-vous après votre
mort l'entendre vous dire à vous enfin
le purgatoire est fini alors
il faut dire Jacques Legoff et l'auteur
d'un de ses plus grands livres qui
s'intitule naissance du purgatoire pour
lequel je vous avais d'ailleurs invité à
apostrophe et et alors si Dieu existe
qui aimeriez-vous après votre mort
l'entendre vous dire à vous Pierre
Soulages fais comme si je n'étais pas là
ah c'est trop joli très très joli
[Musique]